but first we turn to the collective what
is a
national nervous breakdown a temper
tantrum underway
among democrats their allies in the
media mob
and all of their anti-trump allies the
president is now reportedly planning to
announce his u.s supreme court
nomination this weekend and breaking
today
well it appears the senate will have
enough votes to move forward with
hearings and
a vote on the president's nominee now
keep in mind there have been
29 vacancies at the u.s supreme court
during presidential election years
and a sitting president has nominated a
replacement all
29 times it would be unprecedented for
this president
not to do his constitutional duty
nominate a replacement
and as failed presidential candidate amy
klobuchar accidentally tweeted quote
the people picked the president the
president nominates the justice
that is how it works well amy you're
exactly right thank you
and when the same party controls both
the white house and the senate
oh the approval rate is exceptionally
high 17 out of 19 past nominations have
been confirmed
in that scenario now there's little that
democrats can do other than
make threat after threat after threat
but these threats are
scary and they're real when you think
about their psychotic rage their
hysteria
well just when you think it couldn't get
any worse think again today a very
unhinged
speaker of the house and name only nancy
pelosi claiming
that she could impeach this president
every single day of the week
wow that's going to be so good for our
country don't you think take a look
what is your power to do this i get the
election but you have
you can get up more you can speak out
more you can do more
impeachments things like that do you
have enough power
well we can impeach him every day of the
week for anything he does in fact for
200. people dying well because
look the american people want to know
what we're doing that affects them
directly while nancy pelosi is ranting
and raving about
impeachment the media mob they're vowing
to blow up
their words the system all together take
a look
thinking about the supreme court because
we've lost that battle and i don't want
to talk about
the republicans anymore the fear of this
will destroy the senate this will deter
the senate i would say it's sort of like
people saying hey climate change is
coming
no it's not coming it's here the senate
it has been destroyed as we know it
boycott the hearing not take meetings
with the nominee so we want to see the
senate democrats fight this nominee
tooth and nail no matter what happens
everybody's thinking we're gonna have to
blow up the entire system you have to
get rid of the electoral college
because the people i don't see it
because the minority in this country
decides who the judges are and they
decide who the president is
they need a constitutional amendment to
do that and if democrats if joe biden
wins
democrats can stack the courts and they
can do that amendment and they can get
it passed
do you hear what they are telling you
that they want to do
for example the unethical practice
called court packing
that was last attempted by fdr and
franklin roosevelt tried unsuccessfully
to add
justices to the u.s supreme court in
order to usurp the powers
of the judicial branch in other words
roosevelt was trying to expand the
number of justices
on the supreme court fill the spots with
individuals who just
rubber stamp his agenda in that scenario
the supreme court would become
useless and no longer serve as a
co-equal branch of government
our important constitutional system of
checks and balances would be completely
destroyed
but on monday joe biden refused to say
whether or not he supports the
illicit practice of court packing
telling a local reporter quote
it's a legitimate question but let me
tell you why i'm not going to answer
that question because it will shift all
the focus
joan even released the list of potential
supreme court nominees that he said he'd
release
joe doesn't answer any real questions
pretty pathetic how the media mob
state-run papers state-run broadcast
television fake news cable channels also
state-run tv
allow him to get away with all of this
and meanwhile his radical far-left
running mate
that would be senator kamala harris
telling the new york times she is
absolutely open to packing the court and
multiple far-left media outlets are
all but begging democrats to in fact
support
court packing including let's see new
york magazine vox.com
radical democrats the media mob well
they don't seem to care about any
precedent
they don't care about the constitution
they don't care about the bill of rights
they don't care about
co-equal branches of government and
checks and balances
and they're now threatening to start
literally stack the courts and the
electoral college
and the legislative filibuster impeach
the president as nancy says
every day for any reason and oh yeah
they also want to impeach the attorney
general while they're at it
democrats do not care about our great
system of justice they want to burn down
the system and they're saying so
believe them for them the only thing
that matters is power
in 42 days well actually the power lies
in your hands
if it's an honest election and by the
way part two of my monologue straight
ahead will cover the democrats
latest despicable pretty repulsive
disgusting anti-christian attacks on a
potential
supreme court nominee